[Applause]
no pain no gain but really is it worth
it aside from a small subsection of the
world's population most of us do
everything we can to avoid pain but what
if you didn't have to what if you simply
didn't feel it you could do a lot or not
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you didn't feel pain you might
be thinking that pain-free living is
just another high concept hypothetical
scenario that we've come up with for
your entertainment no for a handful of
people around the world this is a
reality I feel nothing and it's not as
pleasant as you might expect this rare
condition is called CIP congenital
insensitivity to pain it was first
reported in 1932 following an accident
with a hatchet that didn't involve
screams or tears but just because you
can cheat paint doesn't mean you can
cheat death living with congenital
insensitivity to pain would put you at a
high risk for a short life at first your
parents might feel blessed to have a
baby that rarely cries but once you
become a toddler their relief is
replaced with constant worry you can
walk and run and dance and jump but
self-awareness and getting used to your
body will require some trial and error
from accidentally biting your tongue
multi thing too unexpectedly tripping
over your own feet without learning from
the experience of feeling pain you could
spend your childhood in bandages and
casts but never know why this
invincibility might make you popular at
school but not with insurance companies
you'd make an excellent stuntman soldier
daredevil or firefighter
but a potentially dangerous food critic
you'd be lucky to avoid the pain of
childbirth but how would you know if
something was wrong while the world
consumes about 14 billion doses of pain
medication daily the ability to feel
pain is actually crucial to your
survival after all your body is without
a warning system so while you might be
smart enough to know that not everything
is good for you how would you know
what's bad for you drug companies are
now aware of this rare condition and
they're looking to learn from it as well
as cure it for example a Canadian
biotech company called xenon
Pharmaceuticals is studying CIP with the
hope of being able to treat those who
suffer from chronic pain and in a world
where 1 in 10 adults are diagnosed with
chronic pain every year this research
could help a lot of people paradoxically
other companies are developing drugs to
actually help people feel pain you know
it's for CIP but it still sounds strange
doesn't it so far there's medication
that regulates the overproduction of
endorphins but it doesn't work for
everyone and there's still a lot to be
learned about congenital insensitivity
to pain so the next time physical pain
makes you cry be sure to shed a tear of
joy while you're at it no matter how
much it hurts pain is really good for
you because it teaches you to avoid
common threats and dangers and not to
repeat dumb mistakes so no pain no gain
let's keep it that way and for feeling
better just keep watching what if
[Music]
you